yeah instead of instant votes and bits
thinks maybe builder bits but they don't
have to be thought of as bits and and
and I will give ample examples just a
little bit of history when I when I left
Finland thirty years ago our family came
to Stanford one of the books in in in my
reading for the trip was computers and
thought and this was edited by Ed
Feigenbaum and Feldman
and so and then when I applied for
graduate study I said I want to
understand how brains compute and that
didn't disqualify me and so so I've been
working on that problem for for awhile
and and and and have found some things
that actually may bring us somewhat
closer to the answer and so I'm going to
talk about how to compute with high
dimensional vectors and the motivation
for this is that brains represent a
constant challenge for us in in terms of
complexity of behavior that they control
and can produce in perception learning
in dealing with concepts thought
language ambiguity and also tremendous
flexibility that we have not been able
to duplicate in any of our computing
systems at adaptivity and the computing
is very robust in the sense that the
signals can have very much noise and
neurons get malfunction and die and yet
the brain seems to be able to manage to
produce very interesting and complex
behavior it's also it's very energy
efficient so they are those those are
some of the challenges for us when we
think of computing that brains are able
to do and we would like to do and brains
can also provide some notions or ideas
of architecture for computing and first
of all the circuits are very large
and the total number of neurons is in
the human brain something like 40
billion and the total number of synapses
something like 240 trillion this is sort
of ballpark figures but if he tried to
translate as to something else more
concrete to us and I assume that each
synapse is worth just one bit of
information then though all our synapses
they amount to something like 300
million books and if you think of what
300 million books means for a lifetime
that would mean eight hundred books per
day for a hundred years so that's sort
of kind of information that brains are
able to able to somehow make you you use
and deal with and also the Fanning's and
fanouts are very large on the average
six thousand neurons input come from six
thousand neurons and of course an output
has to go to six thousand on the average
and a maximum is something like 200,000
so that speaks for in some sense very
large circuits also the activities
highly distributed is parallel and so
that means that can that means that we
can do if he can do things in parallel
components don't have to be very fast
and just we can get very efficient
computing out of these systems and here
is a claim a very strong claim that I
believed a long time and will believe
even after leaving leaving this room
today and that is reverse engineering
the brain in the absence of an adequate
theory of computing it is it is next to
impossible we can map the brain but
mapping the brain is not same as
understanding how our brains actually
compute the map scan or the tracing of
the circuits can be useful in in terms
of giving ideas for engineers but but
that's that's not the whole story okay
then a theory that we want it has to be
explained
able to explain a speed of learning and
retention over lifetime and lifetime can
be hundred years so eighty years or
something like that and we can
generalize some examples and get reason
by analogy and we can tolerate noise and
variation in data and and many many more
such things so that's quite a quite a
tall order for theory to explain but but
that's what brains brains do so the
computational theory that would somehow
be equivalent has the best to be
something like that and here's the key
observation actually on that is this
that essential properties a mental
function and perception they can be
actually understood in terms of
mathematical properties or high
dimensional spaces and here one of my
favorite examples is a distance between
concepts that are semantically very far
from each other and my example it's like
the concept of man or concept of a lake
they we really don't know don't think of
em as being similar and yet in in a
semantic space these two distant objects
or entities or thoughts or concepts can
be connected by just two very short
links and that's not true in two
dimension one or two dimensional space
it's it's a property of high dimensional
space so the first example man sort of
Wisconsin concept is close to fisherman
and fisherman and concept is close to
fish and fishes and concept the concept
is close to Lake and so just between two
Indian intermediate concept we've been
able to connect to very distant concepts
and the other example man plumber water
lake similarly and if you take like the
plumber and fish there again within
those two routes things with under two
routes they are not necessarily close at
all it and a plumber and fish or are not
close concept
also we recognize faces although if the
same phase it's never exactly the same
on two occasions and then there's
another thing that actually something
that engineers and statisticians sort of
need to need to take a new look at when
we encounter a high dimensional problem
sort of the knee-jerk reaction is that
we have to reduce the dimensionality
brain doesn't do that rains they they
blow up the dimensionality expanding the
dimensionality and this can be found in
visual cortex and it can be found in
hippocampus it can be can be found in
the cerebellum so this there's another
clue from how computing might be
organized and so now I'm trying to
answer the next few slides what what
what do I mean by high dimensional
computing and HD is about the only
abbreviation are you so acronym I use in
this in this talk so bear with one
acronym please know that maybe a couple
of others yeah here we have a computing
that operates and vectors in other words
algorithms are based on vectors and in
traditional computing the algorithm
rhythms are based on bits and numbers I
mean and by based on I mean that that's
what's built specially specific this
ordinary computer has specially designed
circuits for dealing with bits and
numbers and the number arithmetic and
and for boolean logic and of course even
though we we think of them as numbers
underneath which is dealing with bits
the roots of this kind of computing they
actually are compute cognitive science
and the idea of computing with
dimensional vectors it's not really new
already one ointment anticipated and in
his book close published posthumously
the computer and the brain he begins to
think of you know what kind of computing
actually is the brain doing then they're
in a sixty Service Rosen perceptron sort
of on the same line 70s and 80s
artificial neural nets parallel
distributed processing connectionism and
those elsewhere terms that became became
much used and algorithms developed and
some of that artificial neural network
were continues today and sort of found
in in pretty much all of what's called
deep learning and then in 1990s plates
holographics reduced representation and
and that I consider the first sign when
we have sort of a complete system of
computing and and and that's what
computing complete system of computing
with high dimensional vectors and that's
what I will be explaining in more detail
so I said that's not new but what is new
and what is new is that we have
nanotechnology for building very large
circuits and this is this will be I
would say in a computer engineering is
this will be the big thing that that the
companies can provide for us and what we
have to in return give them mathematical
theory that sort of is a good complement
for for the circuits that engineers will
be able to build ok now imma go through
an example of one algorithm it's a very
surprisingly simple and it is
surprisingly powerful but this is just
to give you an idea of what kinds of
operations on the vectors we use and
what kinds of results it can give us
the motivation for this this was done as
an experiment assisted a student project
in in a computational neuroscience class
that at Birth the two students sort of
got interested in his idea and it
produced this example and the motivation
was the people without knowing a
language still can identify and be
pretty good at identifying language by
how they sound if you if you hear two
people peeking speaking Chinese and
other two people speaking Russian you
don't have to know a single word of
either and you those are Chinese and
those are Russians even in the dark when
you cannot see what they look like but
but in this experiment instead of using
real speech data we used text and so
trying to identify languages by how they
appear in print and the method the
method of in this algorithm is that for
each language and and for each text
sentence we compute a high dimensional
profile and and then we compare the
profiles to see which language is and
what correspond with which test
sentences so so that was the task and
and that vectors we use here ten
thousand dimensional so we have ten
thousand dimensional profile for each of
the language these ten thousand
dimensional profile for each of the test
sentences and then we just compare
profiles with a simple simple metal
image the cosine is a very very good and
that's close we used cosine as SMA zero
similarity between profiles the data 21
European languages
in some European languages use Latin
alphabet some use Cyrillic they were all
transcribe into into Latin alphabet and
then each language was framed
about a million bytes of text and then
tested with a thousand sentence it's
just that short sentences and their
sentences came from a different source
so that the training training data and
Ana test data were independent okay
here's how we compute the pro
I go through the several steps first of
all no we have 26 letters in the space
and so each of those letters is
represented by a random seed vector and
[Music]
here using random once and minus ones
would equally probable 10,000 so that
the only average that'd be 5,000 minus
one is 5,000 once so we have these 27
random vectors and we use these letter
vectors with each of the languages and
[Music]
the next now that we have a way of
encoding letters we want to encode short
letter sequences in this example I
explained to him so three-letter
sequence it's also called trigrams and
the example shows how the trigram th e
is encoded and it's encoded by using the
letter the let the the random seed
vector $0.40 random seed director for a
tandem seed seed vector for e but and
then multiplying so you this column 1
column 5 multiplied but before we do the
multiplication we actually rotate the so
the first letter is rotated by by 2
coordinates to the left and the second
is rotated once and and and so now hmm
we get a this multiplication operator
gives us a random random
high-dimensional 10,000 dimensional
vector that represents represents th e a
trigram and so any trigram that we
produce with us uses this algorithm and
it says if you introduce a few symbols
th e mm is represented by t rotated
twice you could think of
that said r RT r is applied to R T and
then the multiplication operates rotated
1-0 they not taking as such and so the R
stands for one position rotate of it's a
form of permutation and and a star
stands for a component wise the
coordinate wise multiplication now
here's an interesting fact that you
probably wouldn't think of right away
but it's very important also this
trigram vector THC it is now nearly
orthogonal to any of the letter vectors
but it's also nearly orthogonal to any
of the other possible trigram vectors of
which they are about 19,000 and once we
have a method of encoding trigrams now
we want to produce a profile for a
language and we add in this data sample
that we use to train for any given
language we just add all the trigram
vectors of the text into a single vector
and so if the if the text includes the
quick brown fox jumped it so and so
forth it gives rise to those following
three letter sequences trigrams th e HZ
space east but space Q so forth
and they are just all added into the
same and one 10,000 dimensional vector
in this case for English and in some
things this kind of vector it has
summarizes all the three letter
sequences and it is a form of a
histogram and now after we have a
profile vector for language for all of
the languages we want to compare them
and which is use cosine major for
comparing vectors and here's here's the
first result and that is
if the language vectors language
profiles
are projected onto a plane they fall in
language families it's a Slavic
languages on the Left Romance language
is upper right then it's a Baltic
languages in the middle and lower right
its Germanic languages now this was it's
very satisfying to see it sort of tested
that a trigrams are sort of like
correspond to our ears in in being able
to able to distinguish without with I'm
immediately use any dictionaries and we
didn't use any any clue from because
some languages have have letters that
others don't know we which sort of
leveled the playing field and then then
used trigrams and then the language
profiles were compared to the test
sentences there were thousand sentences
in each of the languages and the result
we get about ninety seven point three
percent correct and if it was incorrect
that usually was anyway it's in the same
language family so that so that sort of
gives some confidence that this simple
very it's very simple algorithm it it
works quite well there's another thing
that it's not immediately obvious and
but that is that once we have a once we
have a language profile built out of
trigrams we can query that profile in
this case in English what would be the
letter most likely or most often
following th and so the answer is e is
most common space is second most common
a and so forth and of course these are
just these are just the frequencies in
in in the text
but but this but the interesting thing
it can be that that information can be
recovered from from the language profile
with very simple operations this very
same operations that we use to build the
profiles that it's a new operations can
be used to query the language vector and
so we first form a query vector and the
query vector is just sort of the first
two elements of the th T rotated twice H
rotated once and you multiply those
together and then and we use that quarry
vector and multiply the language vector
and it turns out that then the resulting
vector is closer to e than its anything
else and is and next closely most of
space and the reason why this works is
that these operations is a permutation
and a multiplication they they have
inverses and and they distribute over
over the addition operation operation
it's some of the things that you get
from this kind of this kind of
mathematics just to summarize the
algorithm just just just just to leave
you with the idea that we really didn't
do very complicated things and that is
we to start with random 10,000
dimensional vectors for letters then we
compute 10,000 dimensional vectors for
trigrams and there we use the
permutation and multiplication operation
and then we use the addition operator to
finally produce a 10,000 dimensional
vector that represents the language or
it represents a test sentence and then
compare comparison is done with cosine
no and and and his here it's on this
slide the first of all this whole
experiment when it can be run on a
laptop computer it takes less than eight
minutes
and that means training and then testing
it's nothing it's done twice you just
kind of just kind of sweep through and
then and yes here's the answer that it's
equal equally easy to do this experiment
using four letter sequences of which
they are half a million or using five
letter sequences in terms of algorithm
it doesn't take any longer use 500 a
sequence of this 14 million or 630 307
million or we can use any combination of
those if we want to if we want to make a
language vector that contains all
trigrams and all six six other sequences
we just we just add those two together
and the algorithm really doesn't change
other than that in one case to do
trigrams you multiply three letter
vectors the time to do do six whatever
hexa crams you have to you have to
multiply six vectors together one time
so that gives you an idea the best
corocut using four letter sequences
tetra prints oh yeah linguist are known
about talk about trigrams a long time
but they they then in order to program
that they have to build some sort of
table and and and and this is just an
alternate this is this is we're not
doing anything special we're just doing
a different way you're absolutely right
now I'm going to talk a little bit about
the architecture for high dimensional
computing it resembles traditional
computing you can really sort of that
map traditional computing in this high
dimensional computing in a very simple
way that they are special circuits for
us now operating on high dimensional
vectors and in this it would be a memory
for storing high dimensional vectors
that's very standard and the main
difference being the high dimensionality
is that we use distributed a holographic
representation and we compute in
superposition and then we make
beneficial use of randomness randomness
is is really one of the key key features
that we we will return to that in
another example as well now in the
following I will illustrate this with
binary vectors the the previous ones
were bipolar ones and minus ones but the
binary and bipolar they are equivalent
the zeros binary 0 is mapped to bipolar
ones and EXO Maps the multiplied
majority Maps the signed and there's one
one thing that that sort of be aware of
and that is XOR actually in in in
modular arithmetic it is it is addition
but in this system of computing the XOR
is actually is the multiply operator so
so some people when they see XOR these
mathematicians when they see EXO they
think of addition and and so if you are
a computer person you probably are not
bothered by that pure mathematicians is
that as modular arithmetic okay also
then we have something that corresponds
to the arithmetic logic unit and it has
an addition operator
with binary vectors that would be
maturity some multiplication of vectors
in the binary would be coordinate white
multi exclusive or and then we have its
operation permute a rotating of the
rotating of the coordinates and it is
something that we have a new operator we
don't have an ordinary arithmetic and
and it gives additional powers it were
what we can expect from ordinary
ordinary mathematics and then there's a
comparison operator for similarity could
be a Hamming distance in in in in case
of binary vectors also then there would
be a ten thousand bits wide memory a
high dimensional sort of a ram you could
think of it and it can be modeled with
the neural net associative memory so
it's addressed within thousand bit words
and it stores ten thousand bit words and
addresses can be noisy and this kind of
memory can be made arbitrarily large
capacity in terms of in terms of
modifier coefficient it's possible to
make this kind of memory as large as you
need and so you you can build something
it has the capacity for lifetime of
learning and the curious thing is that
the circuit that kind of circuit
resembles the circuit of the cerebellum
so Nature has already built a something
that actually looks very much like the
random access memory for high
dimensional vectors this was already
noticed by David Marr in 1969 and James
James always in 1970 you want
so just test by looking at by knowing
what what what kind of function they
need to perform by understanding the
circuit that you could see it okay this
circuit serves again serve a memory
function so there
something to be said for so
understanding brains in at the circuit
level okay now I will go through an
example how you encode information into
high dimensional vectors in the previous
example I just used letters and and and
trigrams well a trigram example well
it's it is from a different now here I
will take this an ordinary conventional
computer record it's composed of fields
and and so the traditional record is
that you have you have distinct bits in
your memory or any representation for
each of the variables I'm here
representing three variables XY and Z
and throwing acid them having the values
a B and C in a distributed superpose
representation we don't have any
separate identifiable fields things will
be all encoded into the same 10,000
dimensional vector so now it goes
through the example encoding the
information of the record and for that
we first have to choose some
representation for XY and Z and and have
to have some representation for the
values a B and C and in this example I
just assign random 10,000 bit numbers
that have vectors for each each of those
variables and values and the first thing
is that we need to associate a variable
with value at the variable it's called
binding and the binding operation it
turns out the multiplication operation
the exclusive-or is an appropriate
binding operation so here and if you
follow the x times ax star a it's
written here and i just copied it to the
right because i need it
for the next example where now this
shows how the variable Y has the value B
is encoded in a similar way using
component-wise exclusive-or and the
variable Z has value C same thing and
now we want to combine those three
pieces of information as if they were
three fields and that time though I
first adding the vectors those binary
vectors together but now we ended up
something that's not binary and in order
to get back to the binary system we need
to use the majority rule now this turns
out if you have an odd number of things
you're adding and you have no problem if
your even number you get some toys and
you have to have some policy of breaking
breaking ties but but basically that's
the operation of encoding several fields
with their values into a single high
dimensional vector now of course the
important thing that can we get the
value of any of the variables out of
that high dimensional vector and that's
what we go and so what is the value of x
in this in this holographic vector H and
so I've copied again a H and X next to
each other
and it turns out the multiplication
operator will do the decoding because
exclusive voice its own inverse we get
an vector that it's not exactly Abe but
it's approximately a and it is close
enough to a and and far enough from
anything else that it can be identified
with the correct a and so this
architecture needs one additional
element and that is an associative
memory that can find the nearest
neighbor among distort vectors
so yes indeed we can we can encode a
conventional record into a super post
high dimensional record and then extract
individual values from that record using
the symbol that I have introduced
earlier at the might of the rule be the
yeah the holographic vector age it is x
times a plus y times B plus C times C
and and and the brackets just mean that
you you use the majority rule and for
what is the value of x so here we use
this x times the holographic record and
then now we have written the H written
it out and it turns out that in this
exclusive or it distributes over
threshold its some so the X can be put
into the brackets and here those two x's
cancel out each other and so we end up a
and and the other two terms turn into
noise but that noise is not big enough
to to disturb that we can find a s as
being the closest answer yes if the
dimensional is too low you cannot you
cannot you don't get your technology
between the look Victor yeah that's
right that's that's and there will be a
little comment to that effect coming and
now but but first let's say that here's
I'm going to say a little bit about the
mathematics that makes this all work and
let's ask you to pay attention to the
words that are in bold
this is not something that it's meant to
be sort of memorized but the thing is
that we think thinking of is like at
randomly chosen vectors dissimilar to
any vector seen so far and a distance
produces a vector that is similar to the
argument vectors
whereas multiplication and permutation
produces a vector that is dissimilar
through the argument vectors and here is
multiplication is invertible and
distributes over addition and
permutation is in two invertible and
distributes over both multiplication and
addition and and both multiplication and
permutation they preserve distance now
that's that's that's that's that's a lot
of big words but in the point of that
sleight was really that these words come
from feel the math that's called algebra
some call this abstract algebra modern
algebra anyway this kind of computing is
best understood in in terms of an
algebra and so they three operations and
vectors each of those produce a vector
of the same dimensionality which means
that the system is closed which also
means that you can keep composing and a
composition will not get out of hand you
always stay in the same same high
dimensional space and operations in in
in algebra they just shamelessly call a
Madison multiplication and the third one
is the permutation that addition is just
it's a it's a related there's our normal
use of addition in arithmetic
multiplication but but in algebra terms
they just I taken much slightly more
generally in in this system that I have
shown the addition and multiplication
they approximate in algebraic field over
the vector space
and and what is the field I mean we very
familiar in in terms of operating the
field because your ordinary of Richmond
take an ordinary arithmetic
multiplication in addition they
constitute a field and that's if you're
given an area area of a rectangle and
one side you can tell you can compute
what the other side is that that comes
that's what one of the things from from
numbers constituting a field and here
it's just the power the power of
arithmetic can be explained in terms of
the field structure of the operations
and and now here we have a high
dimensional vector space the operations
that correspond to this and multiplayer
but there is an additional operator
permutation which that's richness to
this algebra of high dimensional vectors
and really high dimensionality is is the
key here in 10000 dimensions they are
exactly 10,000 mutually orthogonal
vectors but they are billions so
approximately orthogonal vectors and a
randomly chosen vector is approximately
thuggin or than anything that has been
presented so far and this to show on the
next page a little bit of the
distribution if if you have 15
dimensions in the space you have very
broad distribution when you're 10000
dimensions you can start from any point
and you can go very far in a space
before before before there's a pre-civil
amount of points included now a few
words about contrasting this kind of
computing with
neural nets and deep learning major
similarities both used for statistical
learning from data and the data can be
noisy both use high dimensional vectors
however the dimensionality in deep
learning it's somewhat limited you do
not want to use 10,000 or 100,000
dimensional vectors with the operations
I have used and shown here using ten
thousand hundred thousand sources
there's no no difference in in in the
complexity of the speed of the system
major difference is that the high
dimensional computers it is founded in a
rich and powerful mathematical theory
rather than on heuristics a new code
words are made with the single
application of the vector operations and
then the memory is a separate function
and it's stored data and a consequence
of these things is that the algorithms
tend to be algorithms tend to be
transparent incremental and scalable and
if he contrasts this with neural nets
and deep learning everything is stored
in these large matrices of weights and
it means it's a consequence that data
storage gets entangled with the encoding
of information also neural nets have no
specific function for something like a
cerebellum and however in a brain
cerebellum contains over half the
neurons in the brain that's a summary
computing is based on a very written
often subtle mathematics of high
dimensional spaces
and this is not a subset of linear
algebra the high dimensionality is more
important than the Nate's of the
dimensions operations that it be used
for real or complex vectors there are
appropriate additional multiplication
operations for those as well
and this holographic a holistic
representation makes age there's a high
dimensional computing it makes it robust
and in some sense brain like and it's a
forecast I would say that the new breed
of computers will be built that exploit
the mathematics of high dimensional
spaces and the properties of nano
materials and the simpler more powerful
faster machine learning algorithms
become possible for vision language
Chris for streaming data autonomous
robots and evolving systems and so what
next
we just need to become familiar we just
have to have to start using these ideas
and explore high dimensional algorithms
from machine learning language and big
data and today's computers actually are
quite adequate not just for exploration
for many applications we have at
semantic vectors being a company in
Sweden has has based on building
semantic vectors using these ideas and
we have classified gestures with 64
channel electromyogram and that is like
electroencephalogram need to explore
nanomaterials and build circuits and
systems and we have had support for this
research from various sources going back
to 20 years ago in Japan when I was
working at and Swedish Institute of
computer science and right now more
local
and I just it's a concluding slide I
just put here some names of people and
terms they are associated with who have
been working in this area since 1990s
through 2010 and I think all these
lights will be available to you and if
you're interested in exploring going
into Internet than finding out more on
this subject well look for these
keywords so that's the end of my talk
it's the end of my time now there's time
for questions
[Applause]
what is the reasoning behind the choice
of the the word holographic holographic
I think there's something similar to the
mathematics of holograms in that you can
constantly Emily
okay I think of it this way you uses
this to be representation that I've
explained you can take sussed half of
the vector and it still has all the
information it is test less precise and
it doesn't matter which half or which
wits and so that is in a native hologram
is that it distributes the information
in a way that can be can be recovered
more or less reliably depending on so so
I think that's that's probably the best
explanation I can give I didn't come up
with the term so so I I just make it
educated guess percent of the bids have
to be right why is it why 10k 10k allows
you to deal almost with any any
practical size a day with 10k I think we
can we can build a system that can deal
with sort of if you think of a network
network of peers network I think I think
we can handle a network of billion notes
with the 10k 10,000 dimensional vectors
they're just
see if I can it's really all about the
higher dimensionality the more
concentrated the peak and as the
concentrate that concentration means
that's where you're approximately author
orthogonal vectors or and and ten
thousand seems a very comfortable number
a thousand wouldn't be big enough you
can make you can you can experiment you
can you can find out all these
properties with thousand dimensional
vectors but you would not make practical
systems I think they're the thing
matters is what you want to do with
those what you want the
struck out of those 27 things if you if
you construct trigrams you certain you
end up with certain number of thing but
if you want to construct tetra cram so
pentagram so hexagrams your your total
number of things that you want to
represent it it goes very fast
similarity operate dot product cosine
dot product cosine it's basic it's about
in other words in binary space hamming
distance and and and then in if you if
you are in bipolar space dot product and
if you using real vectors cosine but
they
so how far have you gone with your
studies in terms of simulation with this
how would I answer that well I know this
for instance on your next cell on a
slide that you showed yeah you know to
NSF and the SRC if it's the SRC I think
it is no semi cut not to research okay
not the supercomputer Research Center
which now the CCS I think they fund
research into these new materials and
architectures mm-hmm
headquarters maybe they right yeah there
are the ones who built the processor and
memory machines that Peter croaky but
also IBM and credit hmm there are the
things that I've got a chance to see as
commercial things because actually they
do a lot of this operates at Harbor yeah
now your question brings up a very
important point and these operations
when they are bitwise operations you
could 10,000 parallelism Oh through
those because you do not have to have to
transport things across right dimensions
no there are the parallelism in the
millions yeah and their language they
use is called I was just looking it up
in my database
it's called DBC so what I go see a
friend of mine in Denver that's terrific
being me I go
so I mean a lot of what you're saying I
definitely read in unclassified Hardware
literature light really because the
backgrounds programs
yeah that's how they crack codes under
paralytically and
hey let's chat more yeah are there other
questions
yeah the earlier question how far have
you taken this way over stimulation
I'd like to expound on that sorts of
applications you talked about some
intriguing problems to recognizing
languages I think one of your earlier
examples was that we can have you
actually applied this towards that well
that thing was actually it was published
he just came out this year so so this is
it
this is fairly new and we haven't we
have not applied it to actual speech but
and it would take some work so actually
you have to somehow discretize the
speech space sound space and and that
that would have been more work than they
could have done as I said as the course
project for single or so we haven't we
haven't done that but the work that's
done on identifying EEG signals is deals
with this problem of turning an analog
signal with the voltages though
electrodes evolve it is continuous
analog signal turning it into high
dimensional vectors and and there there
is a front-end that does this conversion
into high dimensional vectors and then
these operations are used the
permutation multiplication addition
operations are used to again produce
profile profiles or classifiers so it
turns out that the these classifiers
then by going into high dimensional
space we end up oftentimes end up with
linear classifiers for problems that in
low dimensional space cannot be resolved
with a linear classifier and so I think
that's one of the one of the secrets of
using existing technologies with proven
technologies what would be of some of
these algorithms are being run on
different computers but but what we hope
that this will open a way for computing
with very low voltages very low power
with somewhat unreliable components and
hmm yet produce results that that really
are significant interesting so that's
where I'd say that's where the Nano or
the new materials comes in that maybe
even some of the analog properties of
materials will come me we have we really
conditional and you know when you call
this at all and you go very high speed
you use a lot of energy
so city in their memory chip ass they're
efficient memory chips that can be
handled well early next year as a
company its name it's a GSI actually my
PhD seizes Israel vitamin this is at the
work where for many an associative
computing so long actually veneers with
the you mention name are David Mark and
he was a supervisor of Shimon woman
named Simon Doonan with my supervisor my
PhD at MIT then he is for emitting here
so my piece it was it and now we are we
are working with Jace a technology it's
a member company now we're associating
as a memory chip so between going to be
compared to prior associated machines
like the star an and the Cameron Bure
it's a 16 safely associating we have 16
processor in shape it can be
extend each vector length on the feet
here we will be we're going to present
how we do natural language processing
associated by the way natural language
processing is one of the areas where I
hope that we will really make some
important advances because now we have a
system where we can actually represent
structure because we can we can in in
some sense we could implement Lisp and
if you think of of computational
linguistics 30 years ago 40 years ago 50
years it was all this programs so and
then came neural nets and that that
tradition was sort of a lot we can bring
these together I think with this system
we can we can bring bring the old
computational linguistics and and and
the modern natural language processing I
think we can bring them together
[Applause]
you